miss board magnus is leading in his  match against eric he won the first game  he's playing with the black pieces and  my first impression on this position is  that he's got an extra pawn and it can't  be bad for black  exactly i mean the question is only how  much  is black better but okay white has some  solid construction now hitting the  knight on a4  but let's maybe take very quickly  let's take a quick look so bishop e76  bishop c5 knight c3 castles bishop g5 i  think this is fairly standard stuff  bishop e6 knight d2 knight bc it seems  like both are experts  this feels like you know two experts are  playing this position  a for rookie 8  very traditional very classy and 94 and  and i think this is the moment when we  can  have the feeling immediately that black  has definitely solved all his problems  and maybe slowly starts to take over  rookie 1 takes takes knight c3